Marks is cited that once he said,
I am not a Marxist.
And I think there's a lot of truth to it and the reason why I got the on and on
and on with marks in the scores because my experience is that,
uh,
many of us do have a very simplistic stereotypes in our mind who caused Marx was
and what his theory is all about.
Well,
he was,
uh,
a creative scholar,
um,
uh,
vibrant mind was ready to change his mind when they're confronted with new
arguments or confronted with new evidence.
And there were many,
many facets,
many faces of Karl Marx of you have seen some of those,
right?
We have seen march starting as a hey and idealist,
um,
being obsessed with the idea of alienation,
disappointed with eagles,
a fluffy idea of alienation,
uh,
bringing,
get closer to home,
bringing it more down to earth,
making probably some reductionist mistake in the process.
Then abandoning yet,
um,
and turning into a materialist,
a somewhat hesitantly and reluctantly,
uh,
van,
he starts,
his turn door was historical materialism in the thesis on fire.
But he also says the point is to change the world,
uh,
through s is a practical question we seen six months in the German ideology.
He is a positive is social science.
I had a point where we start with are really individual and a real actual social
circumstances.
He offers testable hypotheses.
To put it this way,
in modern social science language and the Assamese he remains a positive is
social scientist,
uh,
in four in his major varix.
So he was changing his mind and indeed he was less doctrinaire than usual.
The Marxists Star and easy to be less doctrinaire right.
If you are one of the person who created the doctrine,
uh,
do they Viv,
we'll be talking about von important component of Marx theory.
His theory of history,
and this is also contradictory full the tensions and contradictions,
but it is a formidable body of propositions.
Absolutely.
Uh,
that is actually not a single to Uris.
I can recall who live.
Karl Marx not only has a very specific set of ideas in what stages,
who won human evolution from the very elementary societies to the most complex
one evolved.
There are many who offered typologies of like this.
We have seen in Montesquieu,
we have seen in uh,
Adam Smith.
There were many who did that.
But what is unique about marks that he has a genuine,
he really have a history.
He has a very powerful argument.
What is the exact cause or mechanism,
which links the transition from one form of society to another one?
What drives historical evolution?
Mark's is genuinely the Darwin of social scientists in this respect.
But Darwin could do with the evolution of species Mark's was capable to do in
the theory of history.
It's a genuine theory,
right?
A clearly when you have an idea what are really the cause or mechanism that
links cost to an effect and Mark's has such a theory,
maybe you'll see,
um,
then we will be discussing,
uh,
vapor,
whom I admire a great deal that we have really does not have a such a theory and
as far as I can,
nobody else does.
They're the only downside of marsh theory of history is that history proof to
win,
to be wrong?
Well,
uh,
theories are not necessarily to be supported by the facts.
Theories are there,
you know,
to have it tight enough proposition and to be tested.
But what exactly the theory is the will vary in Mark's own writings and there
are some versions of this theory which fit better the empirical reality than the
original Vaughn and the,
which became kind of carved into stone in the literature on marks.
And this is why I do a little comparison between the German ideology.
We touched upon the German ideology or ready and uh,
and other manuscript that he also left incomplete and unfinished.
He was working on it at 1857 and 58 and was never translated the title into
English.
The overs referred it to grow and reset the air at the end.
The sounds right.
A English speaker like to call it grown dress.
No,
it is grown.
The reset and grown.
This means a sketch,
an outline and that's what it is.
1000 Pages,
handwritten pages written at an a big hairy between 57 and 58 like the earlier
attempts to ride the big book,
the Paris manuscript.
And the German ideology.
When it approached him,
Mark's approaches the end of his style,
he argued,
um,
theory.
He said,
my goodness gracious,
I got it all wrong.
I have to start it all over again and he will start all over again,
just in 10 years time.
And if your ride oscopy Tara,
did he get it wrong in the ground risk?
That's what ivy or tried to post today.
And I was merciful enough that I did not ask you to read too much from the
groom.
This what you read has been published.
Uh,
um,
uh,
as a separate little book under the title,
a capitalist economic formations.
And this is probably the most accessible text in the whole 1000 pages.
It was put together and translated by the wonderful British social historian
Eric hops about fortunately is still with us.
He's 91 years old and thanks God,
he's strong and he's still traveling if you pay him business class.
But we could get him to this,
uh,
class if year would be willing to pay business class ticket,
but year would not do it anyway.
Uh,
he's sharp.
Good.
And he was the major social historian of the 20th century in Britain.
Not a trivial matter because the best social history was in Britain in the 20th
century.
Anyway,
he translated it and you read his translation was difficult.
Yes,
but try the rest of the groom that his son Daniel,
you'll see how easy this text is.
Okay.
Uh,
and the point,
what I'm trying to make today is to show what a fundamental shift that is in
mark thinking from the German ideology to the grinders.
So we will start with the initial formulation in the ground risk.
How he beginning through conceiver of what a historical evolution is.
And this is something we did covers like can rush through all of it very
quickly.
Right?
The idea is what he introduced this for the first time in the German ideology.
Um,
1845 is the concept of the mode of production.
And you already have seen this citation,
right?
Man can distinguish from animals by consciousness,
by religion or anything you like.
They themselves begin to distinguish themselves from animals.
As soon as they begin to produce,
as soon as they begin to change the world to feed their human needs.
Uh,
that is the fundamental insight.
And you may dismiss it,
but you know,
that's clearly a very serious proposition,
right?
That if you look at history over time,
you will become very interested how these people survived.
What did they eat?
How did they produce what they did eat?
What kind of housing did they live it,
how they did build that housing,
right?
How they did move around?
Did they invent the wheel?
Uh,
the,
they already know the wheel,
right?
These other questions you have,
you'll be asking when you are studying the society,
uh,
did they,
could they lit a fire or they couldn't?
Right?
So you were interested in this stuff.
How did they kill the deer?
All right.
What kind of veterans?
They had a,
what kind of instruments they used when they planted their plants,
right?
These are obvious questions to ask.
And he said,
that's it.
That's what we want to,
to see.
And he said,
uh,
this mode of production must be calling on sit and not simply as reproduction.
Right?
And I think this is a very powerful argument.
What he makes it here.
All right?
This is a definite mood of life,
right?
What,
what arms such when,
not when I'm suggesting mode of production,
I'm not narrowly focusing on the economy.
I am basically talking about differences in ways of life and different ways of
life as he asked.
Where puts it there.
First you have to drink and eat and five shelter and once you are not hungry and
hunger and you are not that when it is raining,
then you start thinking right?
Um,
but first you have to feel your stomach right and make sure that you are safe
from the rain fall.
That's reasonable argument.
Uh,
now there are some very important key differences,
uh,
as we proceed from the German ideology to on the ground research,
well in the German ideology.
And there's one important difference histories driven by increasing division of
Labor.
And I pointed to this in the earlier lecture here,
he throws directly on Adam Smith's.
He basically takes it over from Adam Smith's.
That's what Adam Smith's death in the glue and is.
On the other hand,
he sees a movement,
a gradual movement over history,
towards private ownership.
That's what drives the story,
a gradual separation of the laboring subject and objective conditions of the
vernacular.
That's how he describes now human history and doing so separation of laboring
subject and the objective conditions of labor and enables him in the ground risk
to bring back the notion of alienation.
He already seemed to have forgotten and put it on shelf then Helio,
forget it again.
But for this piece of work,
the idea of alienation reinterpreted as the making of private ownership and the
separation of work and end the objective conditions of work,
uh,
is very crucial.
Very important.
There is another big difference in the German ideology.
Marx has a uni linear view of history,
a very deterministic uni linear view of history and this is what you come back
in later and marks and that's dominate a Marxist of various kinds.
UNILINEAR means right?
That you also Saudi start at the same starting point tribal society.
They all process progress through slavery,
few dollars and capitalism with the assumption that they all will end up in
communism.
But this is a kind of view unilinear stage.
Every society will have to go through of these stages and that is a necessity.
That one moves from an earlier stage to a later stage.
And as I said,
he will show the causal mechanism or how it is happening.
The grown Risa is different.
This is a massive description of human history and Marty linear trajectory and
ivy or show you what is Marty linear trajectory is.
And the beauty of shifting from this union linear trajectory to the Marty linear
trajectory is that though Mark's message,
completely the logic of argument up,
but he produces after your rec at the core proposition.
But you can see it fits already in his stamp,
the historical development very well and would argue by Accenture now and I will
extend his argument is even fits better later.
Historical evolution.
Okay.
Let's return now to the German ideology briefly and the sensuality of division
of Labor in this very,
uh,
well,
Maurice described,
right?
Uh,
and Waldorf production between the dialectical interaction between what he saw,
he called forces off reduction and forces of production means basically the
technology room anteriors the labor power and eventually he invents the term
relations of production.
Uh,
but,
uh,
he identifies this big property relations in the later work,
but it,
he tends to use the word,
um,
uh,
intercourse or division of Labor in the German ideology.
A now dialectical interaction.
Uh,
what on earth.
These are the means.
I think I also mentioned once that marks in our letter to angles once wrote,
you know what,
I don't understand something then I say it is dialectical.
So it,
the idea of dialectics was not much clearer to Karl Marx than it is to you.
Right?
Um,
but dialectics basically man's right,
an interactive relationship.
Uh,
I,
you know,
in today's social science language we would say,
right then there is the causal Arrow boy Indian bowls phase,
right?
It's not simply that relations of production that are mine,
relations of production that certain relations of production can blog block the
development of forces of production.
And when they change,
the new relations of production can unleash the development of the forces of
production.
So that is the dialectics,
right?
That the causal Arrow there is not simple that imagination pointing from one to
the other,
but there is a feedback loop,
right?
Um,
uh,
that would be I think the modern social science language,
to put this one.
Um,
as I said that I had in the initial formulation here really thinks this is the
division of labor rather than property relationships.
And,
uh,
I think the,
have seen it reveal,
uh,
this comes straight out of Adam Smith's.
Uh,
what you have read,
right?
The relations of different nations among themselves depends,
uh,
to which each has developed these productive forces,
the division of labor and the internal intercourse.
So that's exactly right.
What Adam Smith said,
hunting and gathering societies,
grazing socialities,
agriculture societies,
commercial societies,
they all correspond to different levels of division of labor.
And that's what marks initially tries to do in the German ideology.
And,
uh,
he deals with the question of the,
property relations,
but he said,
look,
uh,
property relations also change.
But this changing property relations are simply the outcomes of the increased
division of labor.
So it's basically debtor manned by the division of Labor.
If I understand the level of division of Labor Ivy law understand wrapper,
the relationships as well.
Bell sounds actually quite reasonable.
And these sections of the German ideology,
by the way,
were rediscovered by Marxists in the 1950s,
especially marches to were living,
uh,
in,
the Soviet Empire.
There was,
um,
uh,
a formidable,
um,
uh,
a social scientist in Poland.
His name is,
or soft skills and the soft ski in,
uh,
1957.
Re-Read,
um,
the,
uh,
German ideology.
And until then,
you know what for scribing to stone that,
you know,
Marx's theory suggests that this is a property relations which explain
everything.
And this is was what that was the project,
right?
Of Communism.
You eliminate private ownership and everything will be fine,
right?
No private ownership,
these few be rosy,
right?
That will be equality among people,
And dynamic economic growth.
Now the Soviets eliminated private ownership.
Was it then I got Italian society?
No,
it wasn't,
was it a dynamic society?
No,
it wasn't now,
or sort of scheme was rereading the German ideology and said,
you did not do any or marks,
right.
Maurice doesn't say it is property relations,
which is school Shabat Division of Labor.
So of course the division of Labor exist in a communist society,
just not the appropriate relation,
uh,
division of labor.
And that creates inequalities.
Anyway,
that was a very interesting,
get their Beta or soft.
He had a very great reception,
uh,
in a vest and social science circles.
Um,
okay.
Anyway,
so this is the initial idea,
right?
In the German ideology and then he blows seats as again.
We have seen it.
I rushed through of it.
He describes various modes of production this way.
Right.
There is the Chai bus society.
Very brief,
native,
uh,
means of production,
hunting,
fishing,
gathering.
A division of Labor is very elementary and he uses the Sassy sexy storm.
This is only a natural division of labor between man and the man.
The man gather and the man hunts.
We thousand amount are strong and does it,
we know the movie minority,
right?
And therefore this is a natural division of labor.
Well probably you can be forgiven.
I mean he wrote this in 1845 and then he moves on to sleep buddy.
He said,
well now,
uh,
the forces of production beginning to develop in a tribal society,
people just had enough capacity to gather and hunt and fish in our food to
survive and therefore everybody had to go out get.in conducting and fishing.
But now we have new technologies which are more productive and therefore it
becomes possible that some people say,
well,
I am not going out hunting and Ivl got sleeves and saves fuel.
Do divert for me and Dave,
you'll be able to produce what is necessarily for death survival.
I give them only as much that they do not die from hunger.
I,
he dressed and between [inaudible] and then I just sit at home and I am writing
philosophy.
So ancient philosophies worn right?
You'll Plato is sitting at home and thinking and you are writing a drama and
poor [inaudible] and you create hearth.
Because the slave side working the fields,
producing a surplus but can be appropriated from them.
Division of labor increases as technology increased.
Well and as a result,
some change in property relationships.
Right now this is not a communal relationship.
Yeah.
Not Members of the same community,
but a pretty oppressive relationship between slave and slave owner.
Then he goes on and then comes fewer dollars.
And what happens with feudalism?
They all uh,
uh,
what is the problem in the slaves?
The problem with the sleeves,
uh,
that they have absolutely no interest in producing.
They were simply physically course to produce.
Therefore they can be pretty negligent in operating the means of instrument.
You have to supervise them.
You beat them right to make them work right or you keep killing them.
You know,
if they disobey this trouble,
you don't have to conduct wars all the time,
right.
To get new slaves.
Therefore an s technology develops.
You need a labor force,
which is more motivated to work harder.
So slave side being replaced by serves my assets.
And what is the big change?
The big change is that now the peasants who will get a plot,
they can cultivate themselves.
The actual do you have to work only for two or three days or the on the largest
state of the feudal Lord.
And the rest of the time they can see at home are cultivate the land.
They can build their house,
they can have their family,
they can marry and their children will belong to them rather than to the Lord.
Right?
Big Change,
right?
In classical states of slavery,
the children,
there are no marriage,
no home,
right?
Slaves.
The lifts in barracks,
right?
The institution of family does not exist.
I mean,
you know,
slavery in the south of the United States was not quite classical slaverly in
Greece and Rome or in Egypt,
but had some similarities,
right?
Slave owners certainly had clean,
uh,
on the children,
of,
um,
uh,
of slaves.
And in many instances,
a marriage was really not really an existing institution,
even in even in 19th century,
us now the surface are very different.
They have their family,
they have their home.
Uh,
they do not have that title of the land.
And the home,
but did they have possession of the land and the home and therefore they have an
interest.
If they don't work hard on those two days,
uh,
on the land of the landlords,
they are kicked off their land,
right?
So therefore they didn't have to pay more attention.
That's the idea.
But then he looks at,
you know,
calm peers,
uh,
the doll come Middle Ages in Europe,
right?
The peaks of few dogs.
Uh,
it,
Rome and Greece and Athens.
And he said,
did the division of Labor increase?
He said,
no,
they,
the division of Labor decreased.
I mean,
antiquity that was discovered in renaissance was far superior to the Middle
Ages.
The big cities like Rome,
we were abandoned.
Many of you have early in the room,
even now you see ruins,
right?
The glorious room,
right.
Was left as a grazing land for the sheep,
right?
Those lands,
you know,
they could,
uh,
bring water into your homes,
right?
The grease,
they had high levels of technologies.
They have highly developed industries.
This was all forgotten in the Middle Ages,
right?
So what the middle is the Middle Ages.
Some people said this was a step back.
What historic colleague,
alright,
inquisition,
the Darth middle age is the decay of the cities.
It's a better step backward now.
Maurice doesn't know what to do with it,
right?
And there's our shed pointed out,
he abandons the manuscript here.
He said,
well,
the theory doesn't work.
I cannot explain this or increasing division of labor.
Uh,
then of course would be the forest small should be capitalism.
And as he's beginning to develop the form of capitalism,
he beginning to develop now,
uh,
the notion of relations of production,
really a few dollars Miss Superior,
this idea comes up right in,
uh,
the German ideology superior to the Middle Ages because it had more developed,
the relations of production more develop property relations.
It was a further step.
Dover's private ownership was a further step because now the Labor had
possessions,
uh,
of,
of the land what they cultivated.
Now,
uh,
and here,
here it comes to classical and Marxist view of what he will change in the
[inaudible] about historical change.
And this is I think,
a provocative,
important statement that he said,
if I'm looking at a mode of production,
we can characterize them by the correspondence of the forces and relations of
production.
A certain level of forces of production required a certain type of relations of
production,
a certain type of relationship between individuals.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
in Mark's Rut a hundred years later in social sciences were called
structuralism.
This is a typical structurally statements,
right?
That you have correspondences of the different elements of the system.
You are analyzing a correspondence of the forces and the relations of
production.
And then he goes further and now we begin to see how he develops the causal
mechanism of change.
It says that is the development of forces of production,
uh,
to use,
the term of a contemporary Marxists.
Eric all in right is sticky down.
Sneaky down means that the forces of production can only become more complex.
You don't forget,
actually,
it's not true,
but that's the theory,
right?
You don't forget more advanced technologies.
Technology is always advancing.
But,
uh,
the growing,
evolving technology eventually gets into conflict with the relations of
production between the property relationships and social relationship.
It's in society,
they become outdated,
so outdated because as I pointed out,
the service slaves were not sufficiently attempted to technology and the service
were more attentive but not sufficiently attentive.
The serfs were not,
did not have such a high incentives to work very hard bit complex technologies,
then you guys feel be venue will be in a job,
right?
Because you will be highly paid and highly skill and you'll have fringe benefits
and you don't want to be fired,
right?
And you will put your skills to use and therefore you will be able to use very
big great care that the computers you use are not being damaged as you are using
them,
right?
So therefore you have to become a wage labor to have these very high incentive
to work very hard and to be very careful,
uh,
with uh,
the instruments,
what you are using.
And then he says,
therefore what happens is that eventually these outmoded social relationships
becoming a conflict with the forces of production and the to have more the vom
to have development,
right?
And therefore a bit,
one point,
uh,
there will be attention between the outmoded outlived all relations of
production and the need to create new spaces for the development of forces of
production.
And this is the revolutionary moment as Mars,
the fancy,
this is the time when the revolution will come because this is when we will rise
against the old social relationship and replace them with new social
relationships.
Right?
Which will create new space for further growth.
The development of forces of production.
Again,
you know,
just to make clear or vague,
one after often misunderstood idea of March,
March,
they never said that capitalism is not effective.
On the contrary,
Maurice said capitalism was the most productive system in human see history.
He said in the last hundred years of capitalism,
we achieved the more progress than in the whole human history.
All that Marx said he wrongly sets.
So he proved to be false.
That if you never,
not not,
we'll go on forever.
At one point,
capital is like any other previous more so production view,
get in conflict with his relations of production and that's when the revolution
will have to come,
right?
And so far we know that Mark's proof to be wrong.
He underestimated the extra ordinary capacity of capitalism to adapt the major
challenges.
Right?
We just have seen it in the last 18 months,
right?
Barely an old capitol is,
was grumbling.
Laura writes,
you know,
just think about the layman's brothers right thing.
Think back in March.
Well,
you know,
this was very shaky.
Really turf,
it looks like it probably does,
right?
They learned how to recover.
Anyway,
Mark's point was capitalism was really a big revolution and unleash the
development of forces of production.
Now we want to grown reason.
What are your major contribution then?
Years later
now,
uh,
first of all,
now the evolution of modes of production is described.
The,
the changes in property relations.
This is basically where the German ideology ends.
He started their own point division of labor and now property relations is a
central idea.
And drive that ownership is now defined in a new way.
He said,
what is private ownership?
Then the subjective,
uh,
um,
laboring subject is completely separated from the objective conditions of labor.
Right?
You can see this is a big step forward from uh,
the baddies manuscript right there.
The essence of alienation was,
uh,
a commodity relationships.
Now it is not commodity relationship.
He captures the essence right of alienation in the nature of private ownership.
Um,
and vv we'll talk about what that exactly means at the transition.
Therefore to capitalism is a separation of workers and the conditions of labor.
And Mars puts it very powerfully.
This is an idea of which then comes back and haunts us all the time.
This is an idea of if you'll be able to read in Max Weber's as well,
the big progress,
what is happening that the worker becomes three in a double sense of the term
that is of capitalism is producing in contrast to traditional or feudal society.
They became free.
I got slave and now there is a civil war and it is declare no more slavery.
I am legally free bought.
Said,
yes,
capitalism produce legal freedom and legal equality,
but it also kicks you off their land forces.
You go to the city and forces you to sell your labor.
So you are also freed from your possession.
So you don't have the means of procession.
What a farmer had to some extent,
even a slave at some,
but certainly,
um,
the peasants do,
they have that means of subsistence.
Now capitalism requires that people do not have the means of subsistence,
that you have to go to the supermarket to buy your egg,
right?
The system will not work very well.
If in your backyard you could grow everything what you need,
right?
The incentive for you to work will be substantially reduced.
Fortunately,
the cannot grow our vegetables,
what we need and they have to drive to get to work when we have to drive to get
anywhere and we have to buy gasoline and we are also therefore forced to sell
our labor force.
This means that three in the door sense of the term,
right?
Legally free and freed from the means of subsistence.
Right?
Uh,
the notion of freedom,
of course,
sad with some irony.
Okay.
Uh,
and then the force proposition multicollinearity,
right?
There are various ways so se can take from a tribal society and he rice about
antiquity,
he invents the notion of the easier dick mode,
but he never used before.
Or Labor is talking about the Slavic form and the Germanic form.
And rather than talking about most of production marks in the ground research
writing about social formations or economic formations,
a very interesting change.
Uh,
it's not,
uh,
just the change of terms.
It's very important change in the theory.
Okay.
Just very briefly about the evolution of the mortar production and changing
property relations.
Now he said in all free capitalist formations,
now there is an appropriation of natural conditions of labor of the earth has an
original instrument of labor and the individuals simply regards the objective
conditions as his own.
There is no separation really of the objective conditions and the labor.
Slavery is the clearest example,
right?
Um,
the Greek sad,
the slave is a working animal,
right?
The slave was treated as an object,
but it's not really seen as a subject.
The sleeve did not have the rights of an individual subject that we'll know
individual liberties for the subject.
I mean that it from slavery to slave,
only about in antiquity.
Right?
That was the idea.
A little Stepford that obey,
right.
Uh,
they actually have,
do not have ownership,
but have possession of the means of production.
The are not treated as legally free individuals and subjects.
Uh,
think about the right to the first night,
right?
The feudal lord had to write a,
to spend the first night,
um,
with uh,
bid,
the bright,
uh,
indicators of her bed.
The,
uh,
you have seen the opera most sad,
the marriage of Figaro,
right?
You remember about the story is,
um,
got always in deeply in love with Susanna,
and wants to marry her.
And he is scared that the landlord wants to live,
had the right of the first night.
He does not want the Lord to spend the first night we were at his right.
Okay.
That's the story,
right?
Um,
and important 18th century story.
Anyway,
so it's not quite a subject.
The Vercher riverkeeper is a subject.
Yeah.
All right.
Let me just move on to private ownership.
He sat under capitalism.
Uh,
the work,
the object are completely separated from the very care.
Uh,
and here is,
uh,
right.
Uh,
the idea that we have these double separation,
right?
You know,
separated from the means of our existence and we are also legally free.
Okay.
And more,
uh,
citation of the sky.
And,
uh,
it's also very important,
right,
that the transition to market economy happens by pushing people off the land and
forcing them into the cities to become laborers will depend only on the wage,
what they earn on the labor market.
And now,
uh,
gums,
a few more minutes and intriguing guy idea,
these multiple trajectories she described,
right?
So the initial idea was a uni linear trajectory.
That means just do it this way.
This was the idea,
tribal society,
uh,
the leads to slave society.
That leaves the feudal society
and that's leads to capitalism.
Okay.
Right?
And dialectics.
So relations
forest,
it was awful abduction.
This dive sleeplessness,
right?
It happens through breaks,
These are revolutions.
Okay.
It should lead from one to the next.
And these nine alactic crawl introduction,
right least for people to throw up the old system.
Now here we have a very different view presented here.
He describes rather various forms with different individual,
uh,
forms of ownership and points out that in fact the uniqueness of what he called
the Germanic form Germanic tribal form,
that it became individual procession.
This is indeed as far as even now we know from historiography a unique feature
of Germanic tribes that they allocated the land by,
uh,
a lottery,
a,
B before each season to individual families.
And then families cultivating the land.
They did not have individual prepper delights in the land,
but they had individual per session are located.
That was the common land was divided up by individuals or individual families.
And that is the unique feature of this.
And here it is.
Um,
and I hope you see it right there on the multi trajectory,
um,
development.
But he describes,
uh,
um,
in,
uh,
the grinders.
And that is,
it's not true.
That true,
that tribal is all led to antiquity or slave societies.
He spends,
you know,
from eight in the morning until 10 in the evening was sitting in the British
library and reading like crazy and they said something wrong.
Uh,
when I am looking at Asia,
that is no universalize the slavery that are slaves in China.
Uh,
but you know,
they ask kind of family slaves that are no great plantations,
which are cultivated by slaves like in Egypt or ancient Rome,
the excessively generalized about Rome,
Greece and Egypt.
The whole notion of slave mode of production.
This is unique antiquity,
but when I'm looking at Asia and in fact I'm looking at,
uh,
pre Columbian America,
right?
Uh,
there is no universal I buddy,
uh,
so he was,
is the easier the form.
He did not know much about pre Columbian.
Um,
America's,
he knew a little more about India and China did not know much.
He,
you as much as usually people could,
um,
uh,
in the,
1850s was reading cavalry.
Uh,
but he understood that this was a different form.
Right.
And the uniqueness of the Asiatic form as he puts it was this were hydraulic
societies.
They were big empires or organize around irrigation and flood protection works.
And in order to have this irrigation and flood protection works,
you needed big empires.
And what the big emperors in China did that they left the village communes alone
as long as they did deliver doors,
taxes from which the imperial power was able to build a flood protection and
irrigation that works right?
So the village commune was left alone as a commune itself and was not
transformed into serves or slaves.
Uh,
China never really had a classical case of few dollars,
a few dollars from the way how we know it from England or France or Spain.
It never existed in China.
Uh,
if therefore it was the easier the form write a centralized imperial bureaucracy
and the hydraulic economy driven by water problems.
And then he said,
well,
there was the Germanic form and I briefly talked about the Germanic form.
All right,
well you had family possession.
And he said,
Ha,
where those few doctors who come from the origin or theorists said,
you know,
transition from one mode of production to the next happens because of internal
class struggle.
Right?
Uh,
the theory should predict that few dollars fell because the serfs had enough.
The vent uprising hang to the slave owners and created a new society.
Well,
Mark said I was a jerk.
This is not how it worked.
Look at how Rome fell.
It was invaded by the Germanic tribes.
And what is interesting,
these Germanic tribes actually had much less advanced military technology and
technology generally,
but they had a superior social relationship system.
They had a more developed idea of private ownership than a hat.
So in fact,
the Roman Empire fell because it was in bay,
invaded by the Germanic tribes,
and they transformed the Roman empire into a feudal society.
They transformed slaves into serves.
And that is also the Slavic form.
Now that is the Russian option.
That is a kind of few daughters about the feudal lord actually treats the option
of the village commune as a unit.
Again,
it is not the central authority in Russia who collects the rents but the feudal
lord,
but leaves to a large extent the village commune to operate in a communal they
and therefore he said,
therefore I was wrong.
It was not internal class struggle which led to the evolution very often this is
an external force which leads to a change into another mode of production,
right into another social formation.
And therefore he said,
well,
shall I say that is yet,
if form necesarrily we'll have to go through few dollars before it can be
capitalism.
No Way.
China is in Ebay or ready have some signs to move Tovaras capitalism,
the south creating feudalism.
But he did not know that.
A gentleman called Mousa Tome come a little later and he said,
and do we have to become capitalist first and mouths that don't said,
but we hate capitalism.
Why don't we create communism straight out of the Asiatic form?
And that's what he was trying to do.
And therefore,
you know,
he had the,
this is sort of my additional,
this Arrow of course,
it did not exist in Mark's right from the easier ti form to come [inaudible] but
that's what Moussa toon did.
Did it work?
No.
Uh,
it Elo,
I want to say probably they're,
the only point is that communism is not at the end.
Communism is before capitalism,
right?
I think set tone successfully converted is Yeti form into communism in order
than to move communities mean to capitalism.
That's what marks did not buy.
Consider.
But we'll be completely consistent with the type of analysis he offers.
Right.
And in,
uh,
the,
grown recently finally about the Slavic form and I am out of time now the same
argument.
He gets a letter from a Russian and are his Verizon outreach and that allows us
to reach was a great admirer of marks,
but she was a kind of populist,
uh,
anarchist left finger.
And he said,
but Mr and marks,
do you really want us to destroy these wonderful Russian optional village
commune that we live so intimately together as brothers and sisters to create
this hated capitalism?
Why can't we move straight into communism?
This is a communistic form and Mark's kind of muddied varies.
So he responded as an interesting idea,
and this is exactly what Vladimir Ilyich,
Lenin and Stalin did.
They call inverted the Russian option into what they called Cohoes collective
enterprise.
All that happened similar to the mouse story.
It turned out not to be the road to the most advanced form of society,
but a kind of side ruled right though vars,
capitalism,
and the question,
what remains to be discussed that or decide Rhoda was national Sherry,
and whether this was the most effective way to move to capitalism and what came
out as capitalism from it is really the best possible capitalism at all.
But that's for another course.
If you think that Iot is of capitalism,
we talk more about that.
Thank you.